the parents of three freshmen at the
university of massachusetts at amherst
say their daughters lost out on a
semester of classes tuition
and housing for next year all over
picture
this picture posting online showing the
students massless at an off-campus party
they're hoping to avoid filing a class
action lawsuit against the school
after suspended the students for the
spring semester refused
to refund their 16 000 tuition they
couldn't even remote learn
those parents join us now this kristen
betsy r.j and teresa
kristen let's start with you what did
you think of the picture
good morning brian um what did i think
of the picture i thought the picture was
i thought the picture was cute um that
picture got them
thrown out of the school just for not
having a mask
for they went to a gathering off campus
on a saturday
they took a picture and another student
uh posted
uh screenshotted that picture off
instagram and sent it to the
administration so that picture
virtually got them kicked out of school
betsy uh when that picture popped up and
the ramifications
uh began to come in what are your
thoughts
um well first of all thank you for
having us and helping us to share our
story i mean this has obviously
devastated three families
um but for us you know we live in
maryland my daughter and i
this picture popped up and the
university was swift and fierce in their
actions they gave my daughter less than
nine hours to move off campus
essentially making her homeless 500
miles from home
with no recourse they didn't help her
they didn't ask her if she had a place
to go they didn't ask her if she had the
ability to
get food for herself this has just been
a
terrible terrible injustice and i just
don't feel the punishment fits the crime
no kidding of course it doesn't rj and
teresa
from from your perspective i know there
were rules
on campus but my goodness we're all
making this up as we go along
so many things that we've been told in
the past i'm totally wrong
and now you talk about march kids on
campus in college
shouldn't there be some play in these
rules
i i i don't think that they were very
clear um
in in their expectations for the
students um
before the weekend when this event
happened
they warned they said you know make sure
you don't gather make sure you don't do
this
uh the week the monday following the
gathering all of a sudden now
anybody who anybody who is involved in
any event is going to be suspended
i am you know to me if you really don't
want something to happen maybe you let
them know what the
expectation is before before um you know
something could happen
um i don't know uh good morning brian
thanks for having us yeah
there was there was absolutely no
precedent set from a suspension
perspective um so our take is
if they say they did something wrong
okay they did something wrong
the punishment they've endured for the
last two months
has been more than enough and the
suspension is draconian
it's complete overkill so um
you know we just want what's right for
the kids like
the the university should allow them to
log back into their portals
so they can finish the spring semester
of course and get their credits for the
spring semester these kids have put in
over 300 hours each of schooling they're
all great students
honor students these are the type of
students that umass should want at this
at their campus
and they need to do the right thing to
start making this right the kids have
paid their restitution
paid their dues let them back in and get
their credits and we'll move on from
there you know you didn't get in a bar
fight uh
you're not drinking and driving you took
pictures arm and arm and a mask
at college who hasn't done that at 1819
nobody uh i just want to read you with
the uh
umass amherst trying to explain
themselves with this statement expecting
regarding parent student responsibility
to follow public
health protocols and the consequences
for failing to do so were clearly
communicated
before and throughout the spring and
students were updated regularly as
conditions
changed closed quotes kristen how much
does this cost you
to not have your kid be able to finish
the semester
it's been heartbreaking watching my
well-adjusted
daughter be emotionally distraught it's
been
it's been heartbreaking um
for my whole family i don't at this
point i do not know what to do
i don't know how to help these girls
anymore i'm at a loss
all we want is them to take their exams
and finish their college path and
they're just
the the school has been absolutely
showed no compassion to us that's all i
want is which what's fair
and um just want the girls to continue
on their path they're great students
great kids
obviously uh and betsy how much money
are you out
you know um i'm a teacher i'm i'm a
single parent with two kids in college
i teach special education um in our
local county school
we don't have a financial pot of money
my daughter took out loans on her own
to pay for school but this is costing us
way more than sixteen thousand dollars
my daughter is devastated
um she is broken and crushed and
she doesn't even want to continue she
doesn't want to go to amherst
you know what i don't play it's a great
school it's got a great reputation
but they don't deserve your daughters
and your kids
uh and they had a huge party when umass
won the hockey
ncaa title everyone was all over each
other uh that was the next month over in
april
where was the outrage on that there was
none uh kristen betsy
rj and teresa um you've all gotten the
short end of the stick i feel bad about
that but thanks for telling your story
thank you for having me all right guys
thank you